>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," ONE OF THE GREAT
SECRETS OF WASHINGTON, SOMETHING
WE DON'T TELL ANYBODY OUTSIDE
THE CITY IS THAT THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO REALLY BENEFIT FROM THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES ARE THE
POLITICAL CONSULTANTS WHO WORK
IN THEM.
THE CANDIDATES THEMSELVES ALMOST
ALWAYS FINISH THE EXPERIENCE
SADDER, POIRIER, AND HUMILIATED.
THE PUBLIC IT'S A WHOLE THING,
THEY GET TO SPEND HALF A YEAR
TORMENTED BY THE WHITE NOISE OF
32ND ATTACK ADS.
ONLY THE CONSULTANTS REALLY
SEEMED TO ENJOY THEMSELVES.
AND WHY WHEN THAT DAY, THEY WALK
AWAY RICH.
IT IS A GREAT DEAL.
THEY HAVE EVERY INCENTIVE TO
RECRUIT NEW SUCKERS TO THE GAME.
THEIR LATEST MARKET IS A
BILLIONAIRE CALLED HOWARD
SCHULTZ, HE IS A FORMER CEO OF
STARBUCKS.
A PAIR OF SLICK CONSULTANTS
SOMEHOW CONVINCED HOWARD SCHULTZ
THAT HE COULD BE PRESIDENT.
OVER THE WEEKEND HE ANNOUNCED
THAT HE MAY GET IN THE BRACE.
HERE IS THE TWIST, SCHOLZ, AND
ENTIRELY IMAGINAL AFFLUENT
LIBERAL SAYS THAT HE IS NOT
PLANNING TO RUN AS A DEMOCRAT,
BUT INSTEAD AS AN INDEPENDENT.
WHILE, DEMOCRATS WERE HORRIFIED
BY THIS, BOYCOTT STARBUCKS
STARTED TRENDING ON TWITTER.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG DENOUNCED
SCHOLZ, SOME OF THE LEFT WERE SO
ANGRY THAT THEY SCREAMED AT
HOWARD SCHULTZ WHEN HE WENT IN
PUBLIC.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED AT A BOOK
EVENT LAST NIGHT.
>> GO HELP ELECT TRUMP, YOU
EGOTISTICAL BILLIONAIRE [BLEEP].
GO BACK WITH THE OTHER
BILLIONAIRE ELITE WHO THINK THAT
THEY KNOW HOW TO RUN THE WORLD!
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE WANT.
>> Tucker: AND FAIRNESS, THE
HECKLER MADE SOME SOLID POINTS,
THE LAST THING WE NEED IS
ANOTHER EGOMANIACAL DAVOS
RUNNING THE COUNTRY INTO THE
GROUND.
IF YOU SEEM BARELY THOUGHT THAT
BARACK OBAMA DID A GREAT JOB AS
PRESIDENT, YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE
PERFECTLY HAPPY WITH HOWARD
SCHULTZ AT THE HELM, BUT NOBODY
REALLY THINKS THAT OBAMA DID A
GREAT JOB AS PRESIDENT, THEY
JUST ALL FEEL OBLIGATED TO
PRETEND HE DID.
NOBODY WANTS TO BE RUDE ABOUT
IT.
AND YET SCHULTZ'S PROBLEMS ARE
NOT REALLY RELATED TO WHAT HE
BELIEVES.
HIS POLITICAL POSITIONS, HIS
VIEWS ARE REALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
NANCY PELOSI'S VIEWS.
HIS SIN IS RUNNING THIRD PARTY.
THAT IS A THREAT TO THE ONE
THING THAT DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
CARE ABOUT, AND NO, IT IS NOT
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE OR
PRESERVING A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE, OR EVEN PROTECTING THOSE
NOBLE UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS THAT
THEY ARE ALWAYS LECTURING YOU
ABOUT.
DEMOCRATS ARE FLEXIBLE ON THAT
STUFF.
THEY ARE JUST TALKING POINTS,
BARGAINING CHIPS TO KEEP THEIR
COALITION TOGETHER, WHATEVER.
WHAT DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT, WHAT
THEY ARE NOT KIDDING ABOUT AT
ALL IS POLITICAL POWER.
THE RIGHT TO RUN THINGS.
THE RIGHT TO BE IN CHARGE.
POWER.
AND THEY WANT IT SO BAD THAT
THEY CAN TASTE IT.
POOR HAPLESS HOWARD SCHULTZ AND
HIS HUBER FUNDED MIDLIFE CRISIS
JUST GOT IN THEIR WAY.
SO THEY HAVE TO CRUSH HIM.
AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT WAS HONEST
ENOUGH TO ADMIT THIS.
>> I HAVE A CONCERN THAT IF HE
DID RUN, THAT ESSENTIALLY IT
WOULD PROVIDE DONALD TRUMP WITH
HIS BEST HOPE OF GETTING
REELECTED.
I WOULD SUGGEST TO MR. SCHULTZ
TO TRULY THINK ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT THAT MIGHT
MAKE.
>> Tucker: THE MEDIA WAS
WATCHING AND TAKING NOTES, EVEN
NOW YOU HEAR THEM REFER TO THE
PRESS CORPS AS LIBERAL.
THEY ARE NOT LIBERAL IN ANY
RECOGNIZABLE SENSE OF THE WORD.
GENUINE LIBERALS WOULD WELCOME
HOWARD SCHULTZ INTO THE RACE.
MORE CANDIDATES, MORE OPINIONS,
MORE DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT.
MAY THE BEST IDEAS WIN.
THAT'S WHEN IN ACTUAL LIBERAL
WOULD SAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE MEDIA IS
SAYING.
THEY ARE NOT LIBERALS.
THEY ARE LOYALISTS.
THEY ARE PARTY PEOPLE.
DILIGENT WORKER BEES, TOILING
FROM THE BENEFIT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY MASTERS.
SO OF COURSE THEY PARROTED THE
LINE PRECISELY.
MICHELLE GOLDBERG OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHO
EMBODIES THIS COLD SCHULTZ IS
RUN "RECKLESS IDIOCY."
SHE DID NOT EVEN MENTION HIS
VIEWS ABOUT ANYTHING.
IT IS IRRELEVANT.
"THE DAILY BEAST" ACCUSED
SCHULTZ OF RACISM, BECAUSE THAT
OFTEN WORKS AS A LINE OF ATTACK.
AT THE STARBUCKS MUSIC STORM WAS
PAINFULLY WHITE, READ A STORY
TODAY.
WHATEVER IT TAKES, AND OF COURSE
THE DUMMIES ON TV NEWS SPREAD
THEIR TALKING POINTS FAITHFULLY.
WATCH.
>> HE MAY RUN FOR PRESIDENT AS
AN INDEPENDENT.
A DEMOCRATS FEARING THAT HE
COULD HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP WIN
THE REELECTION.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE UNEASY.
>> HE COULD TAKE AWAY VOTES I
WOULD GO TO THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
>> DEMOCRATS WARNED THAT HE
COULD COST THEM IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> DEMOCRATS WE ARE THAT THERE
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
>> ARE FREAKING OUT TODAY IF HE
WAS TO SPLIT THE ANTI-TRUMP A
VOTE, THAT IS A CONCEIVABLE PATH
UP THE MIDDLE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> Tucker: OH, TRUMP MIGHT
BENEFIT.
ANOTHER WAY TO LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRATIC HYSTERIA OVER HARD
SCHULTZ GETTING UNDER THE RACE,
MARK CUBAN SUMMED IT UP PRETTY
WELL TODAY.
"IF 21 MONTHS BEFORE AN ELECTION
YOU DO NOT BELIEVE THEY ARE
CANDIDATES PLATFORM IS STRONG
ENOUGH TO WIN AN ELECTION WITH
INDEPENDENT CANDIDATES, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO RETHINK WHO YOU
SUPPORT."
YES, YOU MIGHT WANT TO REDO
THAT.
MAYBE GET SOME IDEAS THAT APPEAL
TO ACTUAL VOTERS, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THE IRONY IS THAT THE VERY
PEOPLE WHO ARE THE MOST UPSET
ABOUT HOWARD SCHULTZ ENTERING
THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE ARE THE
VERY SAME ONES WHO HAVE BEEN
YELLING AT YOU ABOUT HOW VITAL
DEMOCRACY IS.
AND HOW THEY ARE THE DEFENDERS
OF DEMOCRACY.
AND YET, SOMEHOW, THREE
CANDIDATES ON A SINGLE BALLOT IS
JUST WAY TOO MANY FOR THEM.
YOU GET THE STRONG FEELING THEY
WOULD RATHER JUST SEE ONE
CANDIDATES ON THE BALLOT, THAT
WAY THEY WOULD WIN EVERY TIME.
VOTERS COULD NOT SCREW IT UP
WITH DUMB OPINIONS.
WE HAVE SEEN ALL OF THIS BEFORE,
MANY TIMES.
RALPH NADER WENT THROUGH A 20
RAN THIRD PARTY IN 2,000, JOEL